etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem video ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut ich befinde mich gerade hier bei
meinem kollegen das lustige ist der
enorm fußballspiel aber ich hole mir ab
und dann machen wir einen richtig heißen
kurztrip leute ich wollte das schon so
lange machen ich habe die idee von so
lange im kopf der plan wir das gleich
sein wir haben verschiedene freunde an
die geben wir uns alle eine nummer durch
und am ende entsteht und postleitzahl
und egal welche postleitzahl dass hier
in deutschland holland ja auch hier dann
wird es schwierig ist dort fahren wir
hin kein plan was uns erwartet das wird
bestimmt aufregend deswegen bleibt auf
jeden fall dran und ich bin gespannt wo
es hingeht leute die sich sonst gleich
ich hoffe dass wir leicht und lustig
aber ich bin da guter dinge was geht wir
sind jetzt im auto lewis ist auch dabei
ist es mittlerweile schon dunkel und wir
rufen jetzt einfach leute an und die
sagen uns sozial und dann fahren wir
dahin okay dass da kommt meine position
raus okay egal wo also hier halt jetzt
nicht zu kurz weit aber wir können schon
jetzt
die erste
alles wird ja auch kannst du mal eine
zahl sagen zwischen 1 und 10 betragen
nicht warum
ok danke das war's schon
[Musik]
und sind wir die juris stimmen
jetzt muss ich gleich die ganze zeit
nachrichten antworten warum ich die
angerufen habe
was
du ich bin nicht wirklich gar nicht
lange stand ich bin ja mit louis sag mal
eine zahl zu schneiden sind sehen
sie okay danke das war's schon
ich sag dir morgen okay aber
es
geht erst mal kurz die zahl zwischen 1
und 10 bitte
ok danke das war's schon ja
weil ich bin ja wie lange sitzen jetzt
schon heute schon so viele angerufen die
gegen alles dran was geht es wird
auch danke sagen eine zahl zwischen null
und zehn
danke das war
gar nicht so nicht sagen vielleicht du
bist in der engeren auswahl
sind
bei uns in der nähe heißt einfach so ein
dorf auch genau so
will es das reicht um neun minuten
lang omega pharma glos und dankte
er leute werden das jetzt grade
eingegeben es ist einfach mitten im
nirgendwo oder da ist doch gar nix hier
sank feed
und was deiner nähe luxemburg sogar guck
mal das ist zwischen aachen und
luxemburg jetzt leute was geht wir sind
gerade hier auf einer raststätte
sternberg nord alles klar leicht haben
wir in düsseldorf vorbei und dann
richtung holland durch holland durch und
dann geht es weiter nach belgien also
wir haben auf jeden fall noch ein stück
fehlt bis jetzt ungefähr etwas mehr als
eine stunde unterwegs hier lewis hat uns
gerade ein paar getränke besorgt da
kommt da jetzt raus und ja dann geht es
weiter das geile ist musste eigentlich
gerade noch ein paar sachen hochladen
ich habe für den trip extra von anchor
ich bin nämlich gerade mit dem auto von
meinen eltern unterwegs und das ist halt
ein bisschen veraltet hier kann man
nicht wieso beide handys laden und so
und enke hat mir letztens diese power
box zugeschickt das ist ein extrem
fettes gerät das stelle ich euch auch
gern später noch mal vor da können wir
die ganze zeit laden da ist sogar eine
steckdose bei also das ist echt mega ist
aber für uns gesetzt erst mal weiter und
ich bin gespannt wir wollen und dann
sehen wir heute abend vielleicht noch
was von st so leute kurzes zwischen
update und zwar wir haben uns jetzt dazu
entschieden doch nicht heute nach wäre
mir jetzt gerade kurz vor 12 bis nach
belgien zu fahren in dieses kraft wo wir
halt morgen landen werden weil da gibt
es kein hotel was uns jetzt heute nacht
noch aufnehmen würde deswegen haben wir
jetzt die nächst größere stadt in der
umgebung oder die jetzt auf den weg
genommen damit wir morgen entspannt
weiter dann in dieses gebiet fahren
können dann nach belgien genau und ja
das war jetzt ein maastricht und dann
fahren wir es einfach mal hin und hoffen
dass wir da irgendwo einchecken können
man gucken wir mal was da noch so geht
so leute wir sind jetzt in holland hier
gerade über die grenze gefahren 20 nach
zwölf die uhr geht eine stunde vor
maastricht gleich sind wir da okay leute
wir haben kurz vor eins und sind endlich
angekommen maastricht für den sie immer
gefahren zwei stunden zweieinhalb
stunden vielleicht sogar noch länger
keine ahnung immerhin hatten wir hier
eine gute powerplay
powerbox am start und will jetzt erstmal
ins hotel einchecken und dann schauen
wir mal was hier noch so geht und von
morgen weiter würde ich sagen ist ja
nicht mehr so weit ich muss auch sagen
ich war noch niemals trägt deswegen
passt das eigentlich ganz gut ich muss
sagen erster eindruck hier nicht ganz
neu ist im spiegel dass du meine kamera
ist defekt hier ist unser hotel design
und
hoffentlich haben sie überhaupt noch auf
viele
leute was geht guten morgen wir sind
jetzt wahr geworden hier in maastricht
überall gestern noch kurz unterwegs bis
32 oder so vielleicht ein paar kleine
ausschnitte so wir haben uns jetzt
erstmal ein erfrischend ist auch drin
und so sieht maastricht nachts aus also
hier ist jetzt noch nicht so schön mal
gucken ob wir noch was finden wo wir
noch was machen können wir stark keine
ahnung ob ihr viel erkennen können aber
hier ist jetzt ein schöner großer coup
da vorne ist glaube ich ein bisschen
mehr los als der seite also je weiter
man hier in die statistiker wird
eigentlich schon als wir haben jetzt
hier den marktplatz gefunden und hier
geht wirklich gar nichts also das alles
zu außer hier hier geht voll wasser und
das passt gar nicht ins bild weil alles
andere komplett leer ist und ja er ist
jetzt nicht mal irgendwie wollen jetzt
nicht direkt da reingehen das hier ist
auf jeden fall das hotelzimmer sieht
eigentlich ganz cool aus das lustig ist
hier ist diesmal eine tür fürs bad also
so was hab ich noch nie gesehen und wir
gehen jetzt etwas frühstücken dann geht
es natürlich bald weiter nachsagen creed
nach auf jeden fall so typisch
holländisch hier und hier wurden auch
übels viele studenten also hier ist
immer sause so leute wieder hinterm
steuer jetzt geht es nach
belgien da sehen wir uns ja gleich von
jetzt auf jeden fall noch über eine
stunde und da müssen wir heute ich weiß
gar nicht wahrscheinlich weil wir dafür
jetzt zurückgekommen machtoption wir
kommen jetzt an
ab
heute noch zwölf minuten hatten wir da
immer gespannt wie's da sein wird und
auch sich lohnt oder nicht wir sind dort
fast den verstand
leute nach so einer langen reise haben
wir es endlich fast geschafft hinaus
schultern
sagen also wir haben mal nachgeguckt das
sind hier 10.000 einwohner die die haben
leder land möbel guck mal da das steht
sogar auf deutsch möbel dekoration
beleuchtung sitzen wir sind aber doch
einen belgien hahnstätten hier alles auf
deutsch
sondern feiertage geöffnet ist das
vielleicht direkt an der grenze zu
deutschland wir fahren doch die ganze
zeit schon durch belgien das verstehe
ich es irgendwie gar nicht acht jetzt
weiß ich in belgien gibt es ja auch ein
teil wo die deutsch sprechen und hier
ist halt noch deutschsprachig fresse so
guckt jetzt kommen wir hier in ort da
ist nämlich jetzt hier die fußgängerzone
wo es mal schön gucken was da so abgeht
hier in der deutschsprachigen belgier
also da gibt sogar turin vor sankt vith
ich muss über das wissen da kommen wir
trinken jetzt erstmal was wir jetzt so
lange gefahren leute ist google jetzt
mal einer sagen sieht aktivitäten also
wir haben auf jeden fall jetzt
theoretisch schon so noch acht stunden
wo wir was machen können top 10
aktivitäten sank ihr museum das ist doch
gut oder mehr gibt es auch gar nicht usb
mario beretta zählt erstmal was wir
gestern eine gemüsesuppe und das wasser
und dann gehts ums bier museum mehr
leute haben einfach ein eis automat
gefunden ich hol mir mal ne kugel eis
jetzt hier zwölf euro
durch einfach mal kaufen aber das ist
egal kommt
ap the box produktionsdatum mir egal
immer mit einer gewissen wieder im auto
ich habe gerade einfach noch mit packeis
geholt hatte noch nie automaten gesehen
vor problem ist nur was machen wir jetzt
auf jeden fall hier ich hatte mir noch
ein flyer geben lassen hier von st
historische stadtführung könnte man
machen allerdings erst morgen 10.30 aber
wir fangen jetzt im museum das wird auch
toll und saufen uns kein rein ich kann
leider nicht weil ich muss ihr auto
frauen aber muss vorher noch mein laptop
auch klar leute die enka power stage ist
wirklich einfach nur wer sehr hilfreich
gerade in dieser situation jetzt kann
ich mich mein laptop laden da sind es ja
die männer und dank der enka power
station die ich euch jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen genauer erklären kann nicht
ganz entspannen rund um die uhr auch
wenn ich unterwegs bin am laptop
arbeiten mein handy noch dazu
anschließen du kannst dein handy noch
parallel anschließend wir können sogar
licht anmachen wir schon gesehen habe
leute habe ich hier die enka power
station das ist sozusagen eine xxl power
bank die power station ist zum beispiel
gut für festivals wenn ihr mit freunden
weg fahren und nicht wisst ok hab ich
strom habe ich keinen strom gerade für
mich als content rater auch eine super
lösung wir haben wir genug energie raus
um zum beispiel vier mal ein macbook
vorzuladen ihr können ganze sechs mal
euer smartphone damit aufladen jetzt zum
beispiel auch bei mir als ich auf der
reise war ich konnte die steckdose
benutzen man kann die überall aufladen
man kann sie im auto aufladen ihr könnt
sie ganz normal zu hause eine steckdose
aufladen wir haben den usb-anschluss und
den neuen usb anschluss wir haben eine
taschenlampe integriert die man jetzt
gerade auch ganz gut sind und hier ist
sogar ein cast okke dran also mehr die
power station jetzt auf der reise auf
jeden fall sehr gut geholfen deswegen
check gern mal in erster linie in der
video beschreibung ab und schaut euch
das gerät man ist gerade ist nur noch
bei zwölf prozent aber das gute ist sie
lädt sich recht schnell egger verspricht
hier in eineinhalb stunden habe ich
schon wieder 80 prozent akku also ja
worte wir haben hier noch so ein paar
einheimische getroffen ausgang wie kommt
ihr hiervon aus der aus der gegend okay
wir machen das so wir machen als der
natur und wir haben einfach irgend so
eine postleitzahl eingegeben hätten wir
halt hier gelandet
ja einfach sogar
das geht hier so kann man hier irgendwas
machen oder
nein
wirklich
wir wollten noch in seinen biermuseum
fahren könnt ihr das ist das gut ja
sonst kann man nichts machen hier
wahrscheinlich nicht
naja dann macht euch einen schönen tag
befahren
sympathisch wir fahren jetzt einfach mal
ins museum uns ist aufgefallen es gibt
einfach sand fliegt normal wo wir zwar
dann gibt es dann 40 2 so und jetzt halt
wieder nachsagen 41 bestimmt oder also
es gibt drei was an vielen stellen bevor
ich geht so kein 123 weil die keinen
bock auf
jeden fall so wie sie jetzt beim bier
museum aber dass er total klein soll ich
mir irgendwie anders vorgestellt
café restaurant museum naja trinken wir
mal ein bier kann hier fühlt sich wohl
ne also hier jetzt auf jeden fall jede
menge bier nur wir sind ja schön
eigentlich schade dass ich nur alkohol
verträgen kann so alkoholfrei natürlich
lässt sich schmecken
franke aussagen
erstmals hätten
so leute hinter mir seht ihr noch mal
das bier museum und wir wissen nicht ob
wir noch irgendwas hier machen keine
ahnung ansonsten fahren jetzt auf jeden
fall wieder zurück das hat sie einer zu
viel vom biermuseum getrunken an sich
war es auf jeden fall super lustig also
wir können euch eigentlich nur empfehlen
so eine fahrt oder so ein clip auch mal
nach zu machen einfach eine postleitzahl
eingeben und da hinfahren dass wir hier
langen wert ist jemals gedacht dass wir
am ende an seinem bier museum stehen wo
ich leide jetzt nichts trinken konnte
aber das war schon echt cool da drin ja
ich habe mir noch ein paar bierchen take
away gemacht ich kann nicht nur zu hause
probieren
deshalb sicher getrunken leute das geht
ich bin inzwischen wieder zu hause ab
das video gerade fertiggestellt und mir
ist aufgefallen ich habe noch gar kein
ende gemacht ich weiß das war mal ein
ganz anderes video ich hoffe trotzdem
dass es euch gefallen hat macht das
super gerne mal nach es war ein echt
abenteuerliche 24 stunden die wir
unterwegs waren zwar auch sehr
anstrengend mit der ganzen feierei aber
wenn man so zu viert ist glaube ich ist
das echt geil man weiß ja nicht wo man
landet naja leute haut rein vision ist
die woche wieder unter der woche gibt es
ein geiles video haut rein